et notre invité ce matin c'est mon
Seigneur Mathieu rouge et bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
évêques de Nanterre et on a évidemment
beaucoup de sujets à aborder avec vous
en cette période de Noël c'est fête de
Noël qui approche dans un climat social
qui est plutôt tendu il y a une forme de
morosité quand même face à l'avenir des
inquiétudes sur le pouvoir d'achat
comment l'Église catholique aborde ses
fêtes de Noël
aujourd'hui comme hier c'est la grande
fête de l'espérance de la lumière qui
vient pour nous par la naissance de
Jésus-Christ et par tout ce que la
célébration de Noël peut aujourd'hui
encore susciter en termes en particulier
d'attention au plus pauvres au plus
fragiles d'accueil de solidarité
l'attention aussi aux populations qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la souffrance dans
la guerre dans l'angoisse et donc la
période est morose mais Noël vient y
apporter de la lumière on espère que
vous allez nous apporter de l'espérance
pendant cet entretien mais d'abord un
mot sur un sujet d'inquiétude c'est la
sécurité la sécurité des lieux de culte
Gérald Darmanin veut des policiers dans
tous les lieux de culte juifs et
chrétiens pendant ces fêtes de Noël
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet pour la
sécurité plusieurs années que un effort
de sécurité est fait au moment des
grandes fêtes autour des lieux de culte
je veux dire que c'est pas très joyeux
d'arriver dans des cultes qui sont
nécessairesment garder par des policiers
ou des militaires en arme cela dit je
rends hommage aux forces de l'ordre qui
depuis des années sont très investis
pour cela moi je fais toujours très
attention à saluer à remercier avec le
plus de chaleur possible tous ceux qui
sont engagés dans ce service et qui font
que les choses globalement se passent
très bien depuis plusieurs années vous
êtes en lien avec le ministère de
l'intérieur alors je n'ai pas été encore
directement mais en général chaque année
je le suis et j'essaye de saisir les
occasions de de souhaiter aussi un bon
Noël et de remercier toutes les forces
de l'ordre engagées pour la sécurité des
célébrations
est-ce que vos fidèles vous en parlent
est-ce qu'il y a une forme d'inquiétude
est-ce qu'ils se sont encore en sécurité
dans les églises officielles
des difficultés dans les mois les qui
viennent et qui va se passer mais cela
dit je pense que à partir du moment où
le dialogue se fait bien avec les forces
de l'ordre chacun peut être rassuré et
je ne sens pas de grandes angoisse pour
Noël sur le sujet vous nous dites Noël
c'est la période de l'espérance quel
message vous avez envie de délivrer
notamment à la jeunesse qu'on dit des
abusés qu'on dit anxieuse notamment face
aux changements climatique et face à
l'avenir
de grandes crises crises internationale
avec ceux qui se passe en Ukraine et
ailleurs je pense à la mairie par
exemple crise écologique vous le dites
crise sociale en France crise
énergétiques etc mais précisément la
crise ne dit pas le tout de ce que nous
vivons en ce temps il y a aussi beaucoup
de grands des belles choses qui se
vivent et puis cette période de sobriété
parfois obligée peut-être une occasion
de se recentrer sur l'essentiel
l'essentiel pour moi comme croyance et
l'amour de Dieu manifester par la
naissance de Jésus-Christ on évangile et
tout ce que vivent les disciples de
Jésus-Christ depuis mais c'est aussi
pour tous la la relation aux autres plus
fragile en particulier la solidarité
l'attention aussi aux réalités les plus
riches de la culture l'accompagnement
des personnes en fin de vie tout cela
c'est un lieu de solidarité et
d'espérance et donc à tous ceux qui sont
effectivement dans la morosité je dis ne
vous laissez pas enfermer dans la
morosité ouvrez vos cœurs et ouvrez-vous
à l'essentiel ouvrez-vous aux autres et
vous ne le regretterez pas est-ce que
Noël a encore un sens religieux
aujourd'hui où c'est devenu une fête
plus consumériste que religieuse
évidemment un grand sens religieux pour
les très très nombreux chrétiens de
différentes confessions d'ailleurs et
puis qui est encore très présente je
pense que les chrétiens même dans leur
situation moins majoritaires qu'avant en
France justement célèbre Noël avec
davantage de soins parfois
invite largement dans leur quartier à
entrer dans la joie de Noël il se passe
de très belles choses dans ce domaine là
mais donc Noël garde un sens religieux
très profond pour les chrétiens
et puis je pense aussi que Noël reste
dans notre société comme un vrai
marqueur culturel certes il y a parfois
une débauche consumériste un peu moins
fort cette année en raison de la crise
et peut-être que c'est une occasion de
se recentrer sur l'essentiel mais il y a
aussi un élan de solidarité de
fraternité à Noël qui je trouve doit
être vraiment accueilli avec joie et
auquel chacun peut participer ça veut
dire que dans cette crise du pouvoir
d'achat dans ces difficultés du pouvoir
d'achat on peut y trouver quelque chose
de positif le fait de se recentrer sur
des choses moins consuméristes alors en
tout cas la joie de Noël n'a jamais été
mesurée par le nombre de dains de
acheter ou le nom de litre de champagne
bu même si je n'ai rien contre la dinde
ni le champagne au contraire mais voilà
donc elle est essentielle vous avez par
exemple la crise sanitaire a été
l'occasion d'un sur isolement des
personnes âgées en particulier dans les
maisons de retraite dans les EHPAD comme
il est important que la période de Noël
soit l'occasion ou des chorales
d'enfants de moins jeunes se rendent
dans les EHPAD partage un moment de
fraternité et donc il y a quelque chose
à vivre d'essentiel dans ce temps de
Noël et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que le temps de Noël qu'on le veuille ou
non chaque année et comme une sorte de
grand appel à la fraternité dans notre
société et bien cet appel il est
important qu'il soit entendu et mis en
oeuvre
la crise sanitaire est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la société a changé ou
est-ce qu'on est revenu comme avant le
temps de la crise sanitaire alors Michel
Houellebecq est parfois un prophète de
malheur avait dit après la crise
sanitaire ce sera comme avant empire
c'est un une formule un peu un peu choc
évidemment mais je crois qu'il y a des
choses qu'on imaginait qu'elle
changerait complètement le rapport au
temps aux activités etc qui ont repris
en fait leur rythme précédent en
revanche empire ou pas tout le monde
tout le monde que notre société de
société a été fragilisée dans le on voit
bien dans le rapport des jeunes au
travail dans une forme d'isolement dans
une vente de solitude je suis frappé de
voir que notre société a quelque chose
de fatigué et de choses de fragile je
suis frappé aussi de voir que dans
certains domaines il y a moins de
d'initiatives qui pouvaient y en avoir
avant donc je crois qu'il y a un travail
qui se fait lentement mais j'espère
sûrement pour vraiment redémarrer par la
profondeur et donc peut-être
arriverons-nous à faire mentir la
prophétie de Michel Houellebecq mais pas
immédiatement dans les années qui
viennent doutez pas une forme
d'individualisation finalement la
société rendent logique d'individualisme
qui a démarré depuis des décennies et
qui se renforce vous avez raison mais
justement moi j'accueille cette
individualisation croissante de la
société comme une invitation à en sortir
à travailler des relations humaines à
travailler toutes les liens de
solidarité dont notre société en fait
extrêmement besoin vous parlez un mot
peut-être plus concret parce que cette
crise énergétique elle a aussi des
conséquences pour vous dans les églises
puisque le prix de l'électricité
augmente pour tout le monde quelles
conséquence ça c'est à dire que vous
devez baisser le chauffage comment ça se
passe alors de fait d'autant plus que
les églises ont une structure
associative qui n'est absolument pas
aidée sur le plan énergétique donc c'est
un enjeu très très fort pour nous dans
un pays où l'Église ne touche aucun
subside de l'État en tout cas dans les
départements non concordataires qui sont
l'essentiels lever évoqué avec Pierre
ouzumaki également et bien donc il y a
du coup et bien c'est important que les
fidèles continuent de soutenir fortement
l'église pour que elle puisse faire face
à ces charges notamment énergétiques et
puis bien sûr comme partout on fait des
efforts pour éviter les dépenses
inutiles et pour réduire un tout petit
peu la chaleur que cela n'empêche pas
les fidèles de se retrouver nombreux
même ceux qui ne sont pas des habitués
de la messe pour les de Noël mais qui
n'hésite pas à venir avec un peu plus
d'écharpe et depuis lover et le message
est passé c'est aussi Noël dans un monde
en guerre évidemment notamment la guerre
en Ukraine le 24 décembre ça fera 10
mois que cette guerre aura commencé les
populations civiles qui vivent sous les
bombes et qui souffrent bien évidemment
est-ce que ce sera un Noël différent
pour le monde chrétien contenu de cette
situation alors clairement depuis le
début du conflit en Ukraine il y a une
très grande solidarité nous avons dans
danser une fondation qui s'appelle la
Fondation San Geneviève qui est dédié à
la solidarité l'éducation et la culture
dans les Hauts-de-Seine mais par la
Fondation nous avons aussi souhaité nous
associer à l'effort collectif pour
soutenir la population d'Ukraine et en
fait j'étais très frappé de voir qu'il y
a eu un très très fort répondant la
Fondation Sainte-Geneviève a été
vraiment le réceptacle de beaucoup de
dons pour soutenir les populations
ukrainiennes nous avons vu également au
début de la crise un temps de de prière
dans le diocèse où il y a pas mal
d'orthodoxes avec des Ukrainiens et des
Russes réunis dans pour la paix en
Ukraine alors le pape François a invité
tous les catholiques notamment à
profiter des temps de prière de Noël
notamment autour des crèches les dans
les familles on a beaucoup prier autour
de la crèche pour porter dans la prière
et dans la solidarité spirituelle dans
la solidarité du cœur les populations en
Ukraine les familles déplacées comme
était la famille de Jésus avec PM autant
de l'occupation romaine et donc ces
solidarité elle est très importante et
puis c'est vrai que vous avez le
sentiment qu'elle risque de s'effriter
ou l'inquiétude sur le fait qu'elle
risque de s'évacité en tout cas
l'invitation du pape a prié fortement
pour le créer dans ce tour de Noël est
s’inscrit dans un effort global pour ne
pas passer d'un sujet à un autre mais
garder la mémoire de ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui
il y a toujours un risque quelque part
les opinions s'habituent à cette guerre
qui maintenant dure et du coup soit
moins solidaire moins présent que dans
les médias à pas les médias sérieux
comme Public Sénat mais dans beaucoup de
médias un sujet chasse l'autre et des
événements dramatiques sont très vite
oubliés
et donc il est important que notamment
les chrétiens et la tradition biblique
c'est une tradition de la mémoire
spirituelle soit attentif à ne pas
oublier ce conflit à continuer de
soutenir les populations et de les
porter dans la prière mais c'est
important aussi c'est que le conflit
ukrainien si dramatique pour lui-même et
pour l'Europe ne fasse pas oublier
d'autres conflits qui existent alors je
pense bien sûr en Afrique ou en Asie
mais aussi en Europe et je pense tout
spécialement à ceux qui se joue
aujourd'hui de manière vraiment
dramatique aux frontières de l'Arménie
qui est un pays qui est l'Arménie qui
est en immense majorité chrétien est-ce
que vous trouvez que ce conflit il passe
sous les radars est-ce que vous
comprenez d'ailleurs que l'Union
européenne que la France n'est peut-être
pas la même attention à l'Arménie
qu'elle a à l'Ukraine alors la situation
géopolitique de l'Arménie n'est pas
exactement la même mais de fait je pense
que nous ne sommes pas assez attentifs à
ceux qui se jouent en Arménie qui
ressemble un peu à l'Ukraine le hokaraba
c'est un peu comme la Crimée le Dombasle
pour l'Ukraine et puis maintenant
compliqué
j'entends son souci d'une juste laïcité
et comme il l'a dit durant le débat
assez difficile sur la loi dite
séparatisme la loi confortant le respect
des principes de la République nous
avons souvent été sur la même ligne il
me semble que aujourd'hui la priorité
n'est pas à faire un grand débat
législatif qui risquerait de déterrer la
hache de guerre idéologique du combat
entre différentes parties des sociétés
françaises notre société est déjà
marquée par beaucoup de de dureté de
violences dans les rapports et je crois
qu'il vaut mieux adapter les choses avec
avec disons pragmatisme que de rouvrir
un grand débat idéologique par ailleurs
j'ai entendu ce qu'il a dit sur l'Alsace
et la Beauzelle mais je crois que il y a
dans l'histoire congorataire des
départements d'alas Moselle quelque
chose peut-être assez enraciné avec
culturellement qui serait peut-être pas
juste de remettre en cause je me
souviens que cette proposition elle
avait été faite par François Hollande
début de sa campagne présidentielle et
très vite il était apparu que c'était
très compliqué juridiquement et
techniquement de faire cette
constitution et
Jean-Marc Ayrault avait confié un membre
du Conseil d'État de son cabinet
la mission de travailler sur ce sujet et
au bout de 6 mois d'un travail très
sérieux c'est excellent conseil d'État
qui était un de mes amis avec conclu que
c'était pas possible en fait que c'était
pas ajusté et qu'il valait mieux
travailler au cas par cas sur des
questions vous savez que la mise en
œuvre des relations entre l'Église et
l'État est structuré par la loi 1905
pour nous l'Église catholique aussi par
des accords diplomatiques entre la
France et l'essentiel dans les années 20
et partout d'une jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État il me semble que c'est
plutôt par cette voie là que s'il y a
des étapes d'adaptations nécessaires on
puisse travailler mercredi puisqu'on est
en période de Noël revient j'allais dire
puisque c'est assez récurrent tous les
ans le débat sur l'opportunité de mettre
des crèches notamment dans les mairies
mercredi la justice à ordonne à la
mairie de Béziers de retirer la crèche
de Noël qui était installée dans la cour
d'honneur de l'hôtel de ville ou non
justement de cette atteinte à la loi de
1905 est-ce que pour vous une crèche à
sa place dans un bâtiment public alors
je crois que il y a ici ou là l'une ou
l'autre polémique et puis beaucoup
d'endroits où il y a une tradition
d'avoir une crèche et cela ne pose aucun
problème je pense que la crèche fait
partie de la culture certains reçoivent
la crèche comme une image religieuse la
naissance de Jésus-Christ en notre
humanité pour nous ouvrir le chemin du
salut et de la vie éternelle moi c'est
ce qui me fait vibrer comme chrétien et
comme évêque mais aussi beaucoup
d'autres voient les crèches comme une
expression culturelle de Noël une icône
d'hospitalité une icône familiale et je
crois que il y a une bonne manière de
vivre la crèche même quand on n'est pas
croyant dans un régime de laïcité et
puis par exemple il y a aussi des
traditions locales vous évoquiez il y a
un instant les marchés de Noël à Colmar
ou ailleurs et ils se sont même diffusés
dans notre pays depuis quelques années
et puis oui par exemple
l'artisanat des centeniers en Provence
je ne crois pas et quand on est dans
l'assemblée des territoires en
particulier que cela puisse être
considéré comme une atteinte à la
laïcité donc je pense qu'il y a un bon
usage des crèches dans notre France
laïque républicaine on va parler de deux
sujets de société qui font des bagues
actuellement et sur lesquels on aimerait
avoir votre regard d'abord la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG le Sénat
dit non l'assemblée dit oui qu'est-ce
que vous dites qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à celles et ceux qui estiment
que ce sera un progrès pour le droit des
femmes alors il me semble que il y en a
une répercussion inattendue d'un débat
américain pas d'ailleurs toujours très
bien interprété parce qu'on s'imagine
que aux États-Unis ce droit a été remis
en cause alors que c'est plutôt la
liberté des États dans un pays fédéral
nous oublions souvent qui a été
transformé par une décision de la Cour
suprême cette question ne se pose pas en
France et je crois que il y a quelque
chose de décalé d'ouvrir ce débat
aujourd'hui en France alors qu'il y a
tant le débat tellement plus urgent à
ouvrir c'est une question extrêmement
sensible mais sensible pas uniquement
dans le débat idéologique mais dans la
situation des femmes qui vivent une
interruption volontaire de grossesse moi
mon sentiment c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
surtout auprès des femmes en difficulté
qu'il faudrait se mobiliser sur la
position du Sénat sur le fait que ce
droit n'est pas menacé et que du coup il
n'y a pas nécessité elle
constitutionnaliser il me semble que sur
ce sujet le Sénat a fait preuve de
sagesse et j'espère qu'il continuera et
un autre sujet sur lequel on aimerait
vous entendre c'est la question de la
fin de vie puisque la convention
citoyenne sur la ferme via débuté ses
travaux il y a tout juste une semaine à
la demande du Président de la République
un rapport est attendu pour la fin mars
les représentants des églises seront
auditionnées qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ce débat est-ce que c'est un débat
nécessaire est-ce que c'est un débat
qu'il fallait ouvrir alors en tout cas
c'est un débat qui ouvre un grand enjeu
d'humanité et de fraternité il a été
ouvert de manière récurrente depuis
longtemps je me souviens de pas mal de
propositions de loi y compris au Sénat
et ce qui me frappe d'ailleurs c'est que
très souvent ce débat est ouvert avec
des positions extrêmement tranchées au
départ et puis l'écoute du terrain
l'écoute des malades l'écoute des
soignants et bien fait qu'il évolue je
pense en particulier à ce qui a donné
lieu à la loi dite Leonetti qui était
une mission d'information parlementaire
de l'Assemblée nationale présidée par
Gaëtan Gorse dont Jean Léonetti était le
rapporteur au début du travail de cette
mission d'information parlementaire les
positions étaient très tranchées entre
les différents commissaires et puis
l'audition du terrain a conduit à faire
le choix de ne pas dépénaliser
l'euthanasie dans notre pays et à
conduit à la loi léonétique a ouvert une
voie différente de la voix belge ou
hollandaise et à laquelle d'ailleurs
certains autres pays se sont ralliés
alors il y a là un enjeu d'humanité et
de fraternité très importante
ce qui me semble la priorité comme cela
a été dit par bien des intervenants mais
beaucoup du monde soignants en
particulier très mobilisés sur ce sujet
c'est de mettre en oeuvre vraiment ce
qui est déjà prévu par la loi en terme
notamment de soins palliatifs il y a des
déserts palliatifs dans notre pays ce
n'est pas possible dans le département
qui dans le pays du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique auquel un certain
nombre de membres de ce comité ont
apporté une réserve en disant mais avant
toute modification de la loi commençons
par mettre en oeuvre la loi telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui là je pense
qu'il y a aussi un enjeu non seulement
d'humanité de fraternité mais aussi de
de justice et de et de justesse
républicaine pour nous dire alors de
fait la convention citoyenne a commencé
il y a une semaine j'ai été cette
semaine
réfléchir avec ses responsables à la
participation des cultes et cet
après-midi il y aura une rencontre avec
les différents représentants des cultes
un échange une table ronde pour pouvoir
dire ce que nous avons à dire non il y a
uneanimité dans les différents cultes
alors il y a une grande proximité il y a
eu une la Une du journal il y a 15 jours
qu'il a bien manifesté moi-même j'ai
publié une tribune dans la presse avec
le rabbin Michael Azoulay qui qui
s'occupe des questions de société au
Grand Rabbinat de France et nous sommes
vraiment sur la même ligne le grand
rabbin Rémy Korsia a également pris la
parole de manière très forte en parlant
d'une rupture anthropologique possible
si nous avions vers le tanazi alors en
même temps ce qui me semble très
important à dire c'est que comme croyant
nous ne cherchons pas à imposer une
vision religieuse de la vie et de la
mort à notre société plus réaliste et
légitimement pluraliste il y a une
tribune signée par 50 personnalités dans
l'Express je crois tout récemment
présentant le combat pour l'euthanasie
comme un combat de laïcité cela me
semble tout à fait inexact j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'en expliquer avec des
signataires il y a parmi ceux qui
défendent le respect de la vie jusqu'au
bout certains qui croient au ciel et
d'autres qui n'y croient pas pour
reprendre le vert si connu de la rose et
le réséda de Aragon et donc certains
soignants par exemple qui sont pas du
tout croyants qui n'ont pas du tout un
rapport religieux à la vie disent il est
absolument invivable pour nous d'être à
la fois dans une relation
d'accompagnement et ceux qui pourraient
poser un geste létal donc ne nous
trompons pas de débat la question de
l'euthanasie n'est pas une question de
laïcité c'est une question d'humanité
autre sujet puisqu'il y a un an était
publié le rapport de la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels au
sein de l'Église un an après on en est
où
alors nous avions travaillé avant que ce
rapport sorte ce rapport que nous avons
souhaité faire réaliser par une
commission indépendante et depuis nous
continuons de travailler après le
rapport de la science nous avons pris un
certain nombre de décisions qui ont été
vite mises en œuvre je pense par exemple
la présence des femmes parmi les
formateurs de prêtres a été mis en œuvre
immédiatement dans l'ensemble des
séminaires en France nous avons mis en
place à son groupe de travail avec des
experts laïques et
éclairs ces groupes de travail nous ont
fait un rapport d'étape il y a un mois
lors de notre dernier rassemblée
générale lourdes et j'espère bien qu'en
mars prochain mais je l'espère fermement
il y aura une moisson moisson de
décision que nous pourrons prendre sur
la formation des futures spray sur
l'accompagnement du mystère des prêts
des évêques sur la manière de se situer
en cas d'abus signalé il y a déjà des
choses qui sont en place mais nous
allons encore progresser c'est une
question très difficile très douloureuse
pour les fidèles pour les claires
également maintenant il faut avancer
courageusement pas à pas et moi mon
espérance c'est que le travail qui se
met en oeuvre aujourd'hui portera des
fruits très positifs ça provoquait une
crise de confiance entre les fidèles et
l'église alors les fidèles font partie
de l'église et s'apportait une crise une
crise de douleur d'incompréhension de
découragement très fort et y compris
chez les prêtres et les évêques
maintenant face à une crise où on baisse
ses bras ou on se retrouve ses manches
et c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
un dernier mot sur une autre peut-être
un peu plus juste vous parler
d'espérance en début de cette interview
on est à deux jours de la finale de la
Coupe du monde entre la France et
l'Argentine est-ce que vous espérez que
cette finale apporte un moment de joie
de communion nationale alors il faut pas
survaloriser le fruit durable d'une
victoire en Coupe du monde parfois aussi
il faut éviter que la joie soit déborde
de manière violente mais cela dit ça va
toujours plaisir de voir la France au
final et je dois dire d'ailleurs que
dans les paroisses dans les aumôneries
très souvent on organise des fans
pour les jeunes ou pour les paroissiens
heureux de se retrouver pour ce moment
de joie et donc
si c'est le joie peut-être une sorte de
prélude à la joie plus profonde et plus
essentielle de Noël je ne peux qu'en
être heureux merci beaucoup merci
Mathieu Roger merci d'être joyeux Noël à
tous vos téléspectateurs de Public Sénat
et joyeux Noël à vous également merci
beaucoup de nous avoir accordé cet
entretien on passe tout de suite au club
des territoires